did you know the rules at the time of
the Collision that if you're in a
collision with someone you need to give
your name and information contact
information
so because I was hit by Mr Sanderson and
he was at fault I assumed that Eric who
was our ski instructor who was there at
the time who was overseeing the event he
said I'm going to leave all of your
information and he said you should go
ski down because my kids were waiting
for me and and I appreciate that but my
question was did you know of the rule of
skiing if you are in a collision that
you need to share that information
claim
overruled I've
overruled go ahead
can you repeat the question absolutely
Appalachian were you aware of the rule
that if you're in a collision you need
to share your name your contact
information with the person that you're
involved in a collision with
I don't think I was aware of the rule
okay
were you aware that there is kind of a
rule of common decency to do that
I would not have left the scene without
leaving my information and my
information was left
did you provide that information
no Eric Christensen who was the ski
instructor with us said he would leave
all the information when when Moses is
saying mommy mommy watched me
that's who you were looking at when you
were direct once when you were skied
directly into your back
I
do not recall Moses saying mommy mommy
watched me on the ski slope okay well
Apple was down further right yes she
didn't see it no okay and Moses he was
the one at least according to Carrie
Oaks was calling your attention
okay okay
um nine-year-old did he want more
attention to have somebody watch them
rather than 11.
not necessarily okay Moses was skiing
above you though right he hadn't gotten
down as far as you he was on my left
and up
I was on the right he was oops sorry
he was on the left side of the slope
um yes I believe kind of a little bit
uphill okay and that's where your
attention was when you were hit
allegedly in the back I don't know where
my attention was the moment I was stuck
in the back I'm sorry
well I was confused at first and I
didn't know exactly what was happening
it's a very strange thing to happen on a
ski slope
I agree I and I froze and I would say I
was got very upset a couple seconds
later okay
let me just continue on here I just
wanted to make sure that I got this all
right I didn't know if it was an
intentional assault of a sexual nature
right okay
um
was he grinding and thrusting or
something or just the noises what's what
what made you think it was a a sexual
assault so that was a quick thought that
went through my head when I was trying
to reconcile what was happening I was
skiing and two skis came between my skis
forcing my legs apart and then there was
a body pressing against me and there was
a very strange grunting noise so my
brain was trying to make sense of what
was happening I thought
am I is this a practical joke is someone
like doing something perverted this is
really really strange my mind was going
very very quickly and I was trying to
ascertain what was happening okay
um and I think you said I didn't know if
it was an accident but he was groaning
and grunting in a very disturbing way
yes there was a sort of grown coming out
of his mouth so
he Anderson that's about five five that
comes in back of you and you've said
that you felt something huge what was
your word maybe just a big a big body a
big body all right and was it just the
front of his body that touched the back
of your body
I couldn't see in the back of my head
sure but I felt a body press against my
back but there was no grabbing like
nobody that he didn't like grab your
waist or grab no not at all no like that
nothing okay
all right
so
skis slide between you kind of freeze
use you end up maybe your skis kind of
cross you end up going down would you
agree that Mr Sanderson
fell to the ground and then you fell on
top
I don't know if it was simultaneous I
don't remember but you didn't fault and
hit the ground correct I don't remember
exactly where I hit okay but I fell over
all right and with Mr Sanderson right
and Mr Sanderson fell and hit the ground
yes
right you're and you're not saying to
the jury that this was in any way shape
or form a sexual assault I am not saying
that I'm just saying what went through
my mind for a split second when it was
happening all right great so you're down
on the ground
and then
I I don't remember if I started yelling
at him while I was on the ground I
remember pushing away because I was very
upset and it was still very strange to
me what had happened
um and I pushed down the hill and I
turned around and I said and I yelled at
him okay
okay I don't think so okay
so feathers heard a scream you wouldn't
that wasn't you no I froze when he slid
between my skis I absolutely froze and I
don't remember yelling or Screaming
until I was very angry at what had
happened okay and so you guys are on the
ground
and then you said to him I think you
don't know if you were up or if you were
still on the ground but he was still on
the ground right yes when you said what
are you doing yes okay like why did you
do that yes and he said I think you
skied into me yes and that's when you
were Furious and said you skied directly
into my effing back
at the top of your lungs yes I did okay
I apologize for my bad language and well
in fact you were screaming that so hard
you were worried that Moses was hearing
hearing yes okay
um and after you were screaming to him
isn't that when Mr Sanderson said I'm
sorry I'm sorry he said I said you skied
directly into my effing back and he said
oh sorry sorry I'm sorry right would you
agree that
Mr Christensen did not see the incident
didn't see the Collision correct okay he
just saw us right afterwards right but
in fact nobody from Deer Valley has seen
saw the Collision correct your kids
didn't see the Collision that's right
okay
um the only person that and you may not
be aware of this the only person who
says that they saw the Collision was Mr
Ramon
yes okay
do you the way you answer that makes me
think that you don't believe that he saw
it
I did not believe his testimony
do you believe that he saw the Collision
no I don't believe that he saw what he
thinks he saw
he said he was at 40 feet away and
colorblind
I don't know how he can be positive
about what he saw especially with how
much he changed his story
well what does colorblind have to do
with anything my husband's colorblind we
tease him all the time that he can't
tell red or green
um but what does that have to do with
not seeing who hit who well if you have
two people in ski gear with helmets on
and you're 40 plus feet away I'm not
sure how you can discern who is who
okay well and I can tell you that he
didn't because Mr Sanderson
categorically hit me on that ski slope
and that is the truth you learned that
Mr Sanderson broke four ribs yes okay
and that he sustained a concussion
correct okay that he went was taken down
on toboggan yes did you learn of that
that day no did you inquire
what is your name again sorry Kristen
yes sorry I was going to say Kristen
sorry I think you have to keep in mind
when you're the victim of a crash right
your psychology is not necessarily
thinking about the person who
perpetrated it
so the answer to the question is
okay did you ever
um ask hey how was that guy that ran
into the back of me is he okay do you
ever ask anybody from Dear Valley about
that I did not because at the time I did
not know that he had sustained injuries
like that I thought it was very minor on
the day and you didn't stick around long
enough to find that out I stuck around
long enough for him to say he was okay
to stand up that he told Mr Christensen
he was okay after
you skied down went to lunch and then my
understanding is you got a massage
so after the accident I met all the rest
of the kids at lunch we all gathered we
had lunch
and I still felt very shaky and my knee
was bothering me my back was bothering
me so I decided to go in early and get a
massage okay
you never did seek any kind of medical
treatment for your knee or your back no
and you don't have any other Witnesses
who sought to support your position
correct well I have a lot of witnesses
who saw the split seconds afterwards and
the positions of the bodies on the
mountain which would indicate very
clearly who hit who
okay do you have any Witnesses who saw
it who saw the Collision no and you're
bringing this claim for one dollar I am
okay in fact your council do you still
have that dollar bill
I'll let you use your own
I'm not going to even respond to that
you you no I don't get it sure yeah I
don't need it you saw Mr Owens waive
that one dollar around right I did okay
one dollar in symbolic damages is that
accurate
it's an actual dollar that I'm asking
for okay but you also have testified
when I asked you questions in your
deposition that that one dollar is
symbolic do you remember me asking it's
symbolic because the damages would
actually be more it's not true Miss
Paltrow that you are just asking for a
dollar you are also asking this is not
for the jury to decide but this is for
the court to decide later you're asking
for your attorney fees in this case
which could be quite substantial is that
not true
so I'm asking for a dollar for me and
then reimbursement of attorney's fees
which is a separate thing and that could
be a substantial amount correct
potentially do you feel some empathy for
Miss Mr Sanderson and this
declining brain you know I really do I
feel very sorry for him it seems like
he's had a very difficult life but I did
not cause the accident so I cannot be at
fault for anything that subsequently
happened to him so his daughter got up
and said he was
cursing out her her daughter did you
hear that I did hear that did you cause
that I did not cause that did you give
him brain injuries that were evident on
his MRI in 19
2006. I did not
there's an implication that at the time
of this Collision you were distracted
were you distracted no were you paying
attention to where you were skiing I was
was there anyone in front of you there
was not
there's an implication that somehow
you're looking at Moses up the hill to
the left
while you're skiing down hill were you
doing that I was not
did he touch you without your permission
he did the sexual part by the way that's
just for a split second you're thinking
what's going on here yes I was trying to
put together what could possibly be
happening behind me
great a scream I think there are a
couple witnesses that said they heard
Some Noise yes when we fell is it
impossible you you let out a noise upon
being hit
I think it's impossible that I let out a
noise upon being hit because it was a
very slow
move it wasn't an impact the impact came
when we felt on the ground so it's very
possible that when the impact was made I
screamed but I do not recall making a
sound until we were falling or on the
ground okay
uh
so a collision when I think of two
skiers hitting each other I I think of a
hit and then a sort of separation
between the two yes is that what
happened with you no this was very
strange
it was a slow in between my skis with
his skis and then like one one thousand
two one thousand ish and then a fall the
defense has prepared an animation
exhibit that will be shown next week
have you personally reviewed that I have
and does it uh accurately State what you
believe has occurred that day yes now
it's not precise in the sense that it's
not actual video of the event right
um
but it it does a good job of sort of
setting the stage and animating what
occurred
there needs to be some clarification as
to what part of the animation he's
referring to agreed it's sustained as to
vagueness and therefore relevant sure
our our uh have you seen the animations
I have all right
not everyone not every witness saw
everything fair to say fair all right
for instance
you didn't see anyone in front of you
but you felt someone behind you yes so
you wouldn't possibly know for instance
where Sanderson was coming from no he
was behind me I'm trying to satisfy the
priorities
sustained
does the animation uh fairly represent
your story
it does
one thing Craig Ramon
said is that Mr Sanderson was out cold
for two or more minutes do you recall
that testimony
to be honest he said so many different
minutes so many times I don't recall
exactly all right assume that he said
minutes okay it's literally unconscious
for minutes did you observe that
that Mr Sanderson was unconscious for
minutes yes no he was not or unconscious
at all I don't know based on what I've
heard from the doctors that you can be
unconscious for a split second so it's
possible he was for a split second there
was an early comment about a hit and run
did you hit and run absolutely not
and Deer Valley was dismissed on that uh
it was a prior party and was dismissed
you recall that that's correct I think
there was an allegation that
Eric Christian Christensen uh
did some funny business with the
paperwork to protect you his paying
client that section your honor relevance
sustained
did you uh
expect Eric Christensen to falsify his
paperwork of course not going back to
the one dollar
Eric Christians you had paid to Eric
Christensen to take uh
to uh teach her son how to ski that day
for the full day true yes and uh was his
attention diverted as a result of your
Collision yes for a while and that one
dollar of uh damages does that also
take into account that fact
I haven't Quantified if you break it out
what a Deer Valley Ski instructor makes
per hour but I think it's more than one
dollar the comment was the word symbolic
was used but did you in fact lose
one dollar or more as a result of the
Collision I did did
you hurt yourself I'm sorry did Mr
Sanderson Hurt You by hitting you he did
and please explain
well when we fell over my right knee
felt like it had been overstretched and
my back hurt
massage
but did not seek medical care is that
what I understood I did not
you mentioned about keeping a low
profile you like to keep a low profile
when you're skiing correct
um does screaming at the top of your
lungs profanities at Mr Sanderson when
he's on the ground keeping a low profile
after an incident like that where you
feel hurt and violated unfortunately
adrenaline can take over an emotion as
well okay
clear as we well we didn't do the little
dance dance good thank you yeah it's a
little dance
um
but when I tried to reenact it with
myself which is I'm sure I'll get for
that later for my children
um it was the front of his body that you
believe touched you right yes not his
arms not his hands correct okay and when
you guys fell to the ground you landed
on him he did not land on you that's
right okay
all right
um you screamed when you fell
the what I remember the first time I
remember yelling was at Mr Sanderson
after the accident but it's possible
that I could have yelled when we were
falling okay
thrived and
went in between yours
do you have any explanation how somebody
if your move because you were moving
right yes he's moving yep
how somebody could I'm just going to
call it thread the needle stick how can
somebody as they're moving down this
hill
have the ability to put their skis in
between yours when they're like 18
inches apart I don't know but that's
what happened okay
um you testified that this was a crowded
run
it was there were people on the Run okay
but you've just said when I asked you
questions earlier nobody was in front of
you
nobody was directly in front of me now
okay were there people in Your Vision in
front of you there were people on the
Run okay it was crowded
it was I don't think I I think it was
moderately crowded on that day okay and
some of the people were your daughter
and Carrie Oaks down below and your son
and Eric Christensen to the left and up
a little bit I believe so okay
um and you've mentioned that Mr
Christensen was kind and patient with
your son he was okay very much so all
right
um You did pay him a lot and tip him
well I paid Deer Valley Resort I don't
know what the resort is their
instructors so that would be a question
for them did you do you tip Mr
Christensen well I hope so okay me too
um but I would hope also if you're going
to use this and you'd had him as an
instructor before right yes okay you
would expect him to be kind and patient
with your son
well he was kind and patient the first
time which is why we asked to have him
again okay great
um
you said that you stuck around
but while you stuck around you never
asked Mr Sanderson if he was okay
correct because he had hit me and I was
very upset
all right you still didn't think it
would be appropriate
to ask somebody if they're all right Mr
Christensen asked if he was okay and he
said he was
meaning Mr Sanderson I think you said
that he mumbled it
said I'm okay
was your head when you came to arrest
downhill
we both of our heads were in the same
direction uphill
so Ramon said they were both downhill
that is incorrect
I the ski actually the expert today even
said it was impossible for him to get
lift off and
that's just not what happened the
comment was that you cursed it at him
why didn't you say pardon me sir I think
you inadvertently
ran into why didn't you do that in a
nice calm manner
again I felt violated I was upset my I
was worried about my knee my back hurt
it felt violating to have somebody press
their body against my back I was full of
adrenaline I was really upset and I I'm
sorry that I cursed I think Ramon said
something like someone gave him the
stink eye your your Coldplay buddy
he wasn't your Coldplay buddy but Gabe
gave him the stink eye or something to
that effect I don't remember that a mean
look
I don't know who that would have been
and I don't remember Brad probably
wasn't too happy that someone had hurt
his wa his girlfriend
I'll let it go
who hit who
oh my gosh I wanna what a waste of time
three words your honor
we'll let it go thank you thank you